hier guy drut je sais pas alors tiff ses
primes je sais pas si les hamsters court
très vite mais nous allons le savoir
grâce à jacques très malins qui va nous
raconter une histoire d'âme stars à leur
décharge ils vous raconter les enfants
sauvés le hamster a très bien parce qu
autrefois on connait c'est un seul
hamster un villa hamster gris qui habite
en alsace et en allemagne qu'on
détestait parce qu'il fait des stocks
énormes dans son terrier on trouvait 60
81 kg de grains à elle reproché
cotillard milla mystère dans un champ et
reste plus grand chose dans l'est pas et
puis en 1838 il ya un savant nommé
waterhouse qui dans le désert de syrie
là-bas voit un petit hamster doré comme
celui qu'on connaissait comme les vaudes
un seul il le voit il le regarde il
comprend pas il le décrit il s'en va
son temps après en 1930 un savant
d'alexandrie le professeur à à ronnie va
dans le même désert ils cherchaient des
scorpions lui le court après un scorpion
ratso scorpions creusent la terre bras
trafiquants scorpions et tombe dans un
trou sur une mer hamster et ses douze
petits s'était dit hamsters dorés comme
les vôtres ces petits hamsters dorés
vous connaissez tous
vous avez tous vu il y tient c'est
l'animal quoi terra ous avez découvert
ce formidable emails tout dans un panier
rentrer chez lui essaye dlbc hamster la
plupart crève et il en envoie 4 au
professeur adler à londres au muséum de
loin au british muséum pour étudier la
ville ces petits hamsters là les savants
se penche sur ces hamsters les études il
regarde comment sa vie combien de temps
sa porte avant tout ce qu'il faut savoir
sur hamster et moins il le seul figure
seulement et hamsters ça se reproduit et
à la cadence de six petits tous les
trois mois
au bout de deux ans le british muséum
était plat de hamster c'était l'enfer
heureusement il y avait les gardes du
british muséum il y avait les
professeurs qui avaient des enfants
les gosses de votre âge qui avaient vu
ces hamsters qu'ils aiment c'est joli
comme tout hamster donnez le nous on
leur donne des petits hamsters et les
enfants commencent à étudier le hamster
il découvre sur le mc oran tas de choses
comme ça on n'avait jamais vu par
exemple que un hamster on peut le
prendre comme on veut quand il a la
bouche pleine vous savez il transporte
ses provisions dans sa bouche à lui fait
des grosses gouttes
alors quand il a les joues pleines comme
ça on peut le prendre le car et c'est
cette faille c'est très facile mais
quand il a vidé sa bouche avec ses
pattes parce qu'ils la vident avec ses
pattes
il vaut mieux faire attention parce
qu'il pourrait peut-être vous mordre et
puis découvre aussi que l'homme
r et d'un véritable pitre mais un pitre
quand vous avez un petit hamster dans
vingt ans dans sa cage vous donner une
petite chaise une petite échelle d'un
tourniquet comme aux écureuils mais
vraiment il fait le clown mais
littéralement pour vous amuser comme
s'il faisait exprès et voilà que les
gosses qui raconte ses histoires sur les
acheteurs et tout le monde avait des
histoires de gangsters la suisse avance
de 10 millions d'haïtiens ses enfants il
y avait qu à ce moment là des millions
le hamster à travers l'angleterre et la
france vont acheter tous connus des
hamsters bon et savants se disait la
chien ses doigts sont vus sur le hamster
beaucoup de choses que nous n'avions
découverte nous si on allait voir au
désert les vrais hamster les hamsters
sauvage
comment il faut aussi gens aussi
intelligents que ce que les gosses
raconte comprenez pour comprendre s'il
s'était l'éducation tous et c'est
naturel on part on le désert de syrie là
où le professeur aarau n'y avait trouvé
ses treize hamster on trouve pas on
quadrille le désert mais on le passif
également au peigne fin
on a pu trouver un seul hamster les
treize hamster que le professeur a à
ronnie avait découvert en 1930 et elle
est dernier de l'espèce et l'espèce qui
compte maintenant des millions et 10
millions hamster a été littéralement
sauvé parce que vous les gosses vous
avez élevé rehab ster et vous avez
appris à jouer avec eux gardent
d'ailleurs sont des gens absolument
charmant